This episode was made possible by Wix.
And we'll tell you more about them later in the episode
today, we're going inside the nuclear reactor and not just any reactor,
but the react to the tooth used to make the rare isotopes of
elements like berkelium California,
the ones that are so important for synthesizing the super-heavy elements.
So this is an old reactor.
And the reason why this reactor is here is because of a gentleman named Glenn
seaboard.
He had a lot of work at Berkeley labs and he had a vision of practicing that
work on these heavy elements, but he didn't have a great supply of.
And we can look forward with the hope that nuclear energy will become the
servant of all men everywhere.
He pushed the atomic energy commission through the fifties,
pushed and pushed and pushed. And finally, uh,
of course he won the Nobel prize in chemistry in 1951,
and he'd get a little bit of credibility. And, uh,
and he finally made some progress in the late fifties, 1958.
And, uh, the atomic energy commission said, yeah, we want to do this.
We want to build a reactor to produce heavy elements for you to do your
chemistry. And so, uh,
the commission looked around the country at the time.
And at that time in the late fifties,
there was a lot happening with nuclear reactors, lots of drawings,
a lot of designs being put on paper, particularly here in Oak Ridge.
Medicos, atomic city at Oak Ridge, Tennessee has been open to the public.
And even the opening was by atomic energy. Watch that tape.
Had the only school that was specifically designed for reactor engineering.
It was called the Oakridge reactor engineering school.
And this gentleman who's on the wall. Dick Sheverton has a plaque up here.
He was a student in that school at that time. And he'd come up with a concept.
And the commissioner of the atomic energy commission saw this concept and said,
yeah, I think this is the one.
Lenti Seaborg needed a nuclear reactor with a high neutron
flux so that he could get the elements to study up till
then he had gone to the sites where they had been nuclear tests
and looked among the rubble for traces of these elements.
And obviously this is not very environmentally friendly and there's a limit to
the number of nuclear tests that can be done.
And people are not very interested in doing a test just to make some exotic
elements.
In 1960,
they broke ground on this site and then they put the reactor building in and put
the reactor in and they were up and running by 1965.
So for the first 20 years of operation, we produced these heavy isotopes,
small quantities, but we produced a very regularly.
We operated very regularly and we operated often,
meaning the total number of days we operated over the year was very,
very large, 75%. Now we operate much,
much less about 50% of the year we actually operate. Um,
and our mission has shifted over the decades.
Now our mission is neutron scattering, uh, condensed matter physics,
but we still have an isotope component. We still make isotopes.
So we got a big window. This is our Bay. Uh,
our reactor is actually, uh, to the right side of the pool.
The yellow bridge has a dam underneath and that, uh,
well that doesn't have a dam today. I can see the dam is out.
The dam is actually moved to the left. We're currently shut down for an outage.
And, uh, but the reactor is in the pool on the right kind of,
you see the stairway going down that stairway goes down to a
platform, basically a grading.
So we can lower that when we have the dam in place,
we can lower that pool and we can actually walk down there and perform, uh,
maintenance and repairs in the pool is the reactor vessel.
We're a pressurized reactor. So we have a very,
a sizeable pressure vessel.
And then the reactor core is actually inside of that vessel.
The vessel itself is, um, uh, it's eight feet across.
So what two and a half meters,
but the core inside of the reactor is where all the action happens.
This reactor is designed to produce neutrons,
not to produce power.
It's not trying to make electricity like say Chernobyl
reactor was so it's small and it produces the
neutrons at a very high rate. And then it burns out quite quickly.
Each reactor core only lasts at its proper operating
power about 25 days, less than a month.
The reason we pressurize it is to increase the boiling point of water so that we
can cool without boiling our reactor because we produce an enormous amount of
heat along with an enormous amount of neutrons. What's the liquids in the pool,
plain water,
just out of the tap water you're purified or slightly diminished realized there
are still some minerals in it, but we do demineralize it.
Water is all for cooling. All we're trying to do is remove heat.
We produce a huge number of neutrons in ways that we can explain a million
billion neutrons, 10 to the 15th neutrons, uh,
every second hit a square centimeter. That's just one square centimeter.
It's a huge number of neutrons.
So the pool water is separate from the water that's inside the pressure vessel
and the pool water remains at about 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
The water inside the vessel starts out at about 120 degrees Fahrenheit.
As it passes down through our reactor core,
it raises about 36 degrees Fahrenheit exits at about 156
degrees Fahrenheit, way, way below boiling. This is good for us power reactors.
They want to generate steam, but we don't want steam. Steam would be bad for us.
We would like our water to be liquid.
It it's blue because there's so much metal in there. It really isn't blue.
And we get that question often, but it's pretty, but, uh,
it's not like there's an additive. So this is a mock-up of our fuel.
Our fuel is different power reactor, you know, uses fuel rods.
We use fuel plates,
but they're arranged in a very strange arrangement for compared to other
research reactors, even, uh,
our fuel is ma is placed in these plates that are in here.
These are curved plates, and we basically have two fuel elements,
an outer element, and an inner element. This part in here, which has rods.
These are not fuel rods. These are target rods.
This area is a area of very high neutron flux.
So this is the business end of our reactor for making isotopes.
When we make California in two 52,
which you may have learned about next door or berkelium two 49, uh,
we make it in here in the flux trap.
The main point of the reactor is to have a tube in the middle in
which you put your samples in fairly long,
thin essentially metal test tubes to be radiated and
neutrons are important because these heavy elements can be
formed by bombarding lighter elements with
neutron.
These, uh, fuel elements are mostly aluminum,
but inside of these fuel plates is uranium. So we have, uh,
you, uh, we use U three Oh eight, which is uranium oxide, and, uh,
it's sandwiched in between two aluminum plates. So we,
we basically protect the uranium,
but allow it to cool very effectively by having these very small channels to
force the water through.
And that's why we raise temperature from one 20 to one 56. It all,
all that heat transfer happens through these plates.
So the plates themselves are about 24 inches, but the, the,
we call the fuel meat. The uranium is really about 20 inches tall,
so about 20 inches of fuel meat. And, uh, and the rest is aluminum.
Our fuel actually the uranium comes from, uh,
the wide 12 national security complex,
and we get our uranium for free. However,
the free part is a metal chunks and we can't use metal chunks in our fuel.
So we have to pay to have our uranium converted to U three Oh eight oxide.
So Y 12 does that, they convert it to an oxide.
And then our fuel is actually fabricated at, uh, BWX T technologies,
which is a, in Lynchburg, Virginia.
They are the ones that take that [inaudible] and they blend it with aluminum
powder and they form these compacts,
basically the [inaudible] and the aluminum are blended together.
They press it into these compacts.
These compacts are then put into this aluminum picture frame.
So now you can envision there's uranium. There's aluminum in this,
in these middle sections here, and this is just all aluminum.
And then we sandwich with an aluminum plate.
Then we take that plate and we roll it out.
Then what they do is they form it into this shape. And this is a unique shape.
This shape is called an involute shape. What makes that shape unique?
It's the only geometric shape that you can stack around a
circle and maintain a constant water gap thickness.
You can't do that with a circle. You can't do it with anything else. It's,
it's an, uh, this involute shape.
Here on this dummy version. I'm looking at these are representing the, feel,
the uranium, these like this, this like pretty fluted area.
Yep. Right? Yep. Both these flooded areas are where the uranium is.
That's where we generate all of our power, our, all of our heat, all of our, uh,
neutrons.
And how are you making sure that most of the nutrients go to the center where
you want them? I assume you want them to go to the center more than the outside.
Well, you can't really control that. However, that's the,
that's the amazing part of this unique design that Dick Sheverton came up with
is this flux trap. He called it a trap,
but it's really just a high concentration. There's no such thing as trap.
You can't trap a neutron, but you can create a high density of neutrons.
And that's basically what this does. However, those neutrons do go outward too.
And in fact, if we look at this mock-up,
this gives us a more complete picture of the, uh, of the reactor core.
So we have our flux trap that we saw over there. We have our fuel,
we have a small region called our control region,
and then we have a reflector region. So these are all annular regions,
our reflector region, this is necessary for the reactor to work.
And so as our control region,
the reflector is made of brilliant and beryllium is a unique material.
It's unique.
Neutronic only because when a neutron hits beryllium on average,
about two and a half,
new neutrons are made from that they're lower energy than the ones
that came in and hit it. But so you get two and a half neutrons.
Some of those neutrons go back into the fuel and cause that fuel division more,
and you build up this population of neutrons.
Some of them can be used for experiments that are out here in the core
and the reflector.
You just let your dislike,
we've got this great nutrient environment and scientists like,
what else can we Chuck in there to see what happens? Yeah.
Yeah. So in fact, out here,
what we generally make these days is we make plutonium two 38 for now.
Awesome.
So we start with neptunium two 37 and we
irradiate those neptunium target for three of our operating cycles,
which is about 25 days. So 75 days of radiation,
and we convert about 10% of that.
Neptunium two 37 to plutonium, two 38.
Then we take it to the hot cells next door that you just visited.
They extract that they ship it out to Los Alamos and
eventually it ends up in, uh, radio thermal electric generators.
RTGS for example, like the one that's on Mars Rover curiosity,
or the one that's going to be on Mars, 2020 Rover.
Between the core and the reflector.
There are plates containing the element. You wrote him.
One of the rare earth you roped him in this context is a very efficient
absorber of neutrons. So it stops the nutrients from the core,
getting to the reflector and the control plates are in two parts so
that you can move one up and one down and adjust the size of the gap
between them. So when you're ready to go,
everything is assembled. The reactor is in its case,
in water for the cooling and everything is shielded.
Then remotely, you can pull these control plates apart.
And the outer one moves up and the inner one moves down and we create a window
of communication between the fuel and the reflector.
So the new drones can communicate and we build up that population of neutrons.
And then we finally go critical. Then what we'll do is for the remainder,
however long it takes, if it takes 23 days, 25 days, 27 days,
we pull these plates apart until they're all the way out.
And once they're completely out and we can't maintain 85 megawatts,
we shut it down. But at any point, if you, if you shut the window,
the whole thing would go out with it.
It turns off what's going on in the center where those where the roads are.
So those targets, we do produce other isotopes.
We make nickel 63. Uh, we make selenium 75.
We make, uh, California in two 52.
And then we also make some of these other elements, the,
like the berkelium two 49. What are the rods typically made of,
or does that depend on what you're trying to achieve?
It depends on what you're trying to achieve, but most of the targets,
most of the components in the reactor and especially the targets
are, have a, have a capsule housing made of aluminum.
So most targets are made of aluminum,
and then they have some material interest in them.
In the case of plutonium, like I discussed,
neptunium two 37 in the case of California, two 52,
we start with heavy Curium, which might be Curium two 46 or cuter.
Curium two 48 for selenium 75. We have selenium 74 targets.
So we generally want most,
most of the processes are to capture neutrons, to get to the next isotope.
We are fairly full, but we have a regular, uh,
routine set of, uh, radiations that we do, particularly for isotope production.
But we also do a lot of materials, radiations testing in here.
We have a lot of materials for material science in that core. It's one of these,
it lasts for 25 days when we take it out,
we put a brand new one in each one of these is about 1.8 million us dollars
and it lasts for 25 days. So.
And then what happens? Is it refurbed or was that guys in the, in the band?
So what happens is, so, as I said, we're in an outage, this is a temporary,
you just a little cap to cover. So we don't drop things in there. Uh,
this is our vessel head. This is the part that's about eight feet in diameter.
Uh, this is the grading.
You can see that you can actually walk down the steps to get to not a lot to see
here because we're not operating. Usually when we're operating,
you could see a blue glow, you get the shrink off radiation glow.
So you slide the core into that area. Yes.
So the it's actually quite deep down in there.
So we use very long tools attached to things and the operators, uh,
roll the bridge over and then they can lower the fuel down into the corner.
She said it was an exciting day for you guys. Like does everyone come out?
And what she gave was starting a new window.
I will say, it's fairly routine. Now putting it in, uh,
taking it out is more exciting, but generally that happens overnight.
So not a lot of people come out overnight, but when you take it out,
you take out elements that look like, uh, you get the nice saran, cough,
glow. We don't have a lot of them right now that are glowing. Um, but,
and actually we, I don't really see many glowing. Usually we would have,
these would be glowing, but they've been out for quite a while.
We've had a long outage, so they've had time to decay.
So these are old ones cooling down. These are old ones cooling down.
[Inaudible].
I always stay under water and they stay in this center section of the pool for
maybe two or three years. And then eventually they go over to these racks,
which are three tier. So we can hold a lot of elements over here.
And then eventually they get shipped to Savannah river site where Savannah river
site will dissolve them and extract out the good remaining
material and recycle that into a program that's
supposedly makes power reactor fuel, not very familiar with that.
Program. How do you get the stuff out that you've just made? Like, you know,
all that, all those cool isotypes that everyone's dying to get their hands on.
How do you get them out of the core and all those surrounding little cylinders?
So that's, that is a challenge.
And I will say that is what our operators do. Um,
with long tools, it's like laparoscopic surgery to get these out.
So it would be nice.
And you look at the top of this and you see these plugs and holes,
those plugs and holes. Initially you think, Oh,
those line up with the holes that are on top of the reflector, but they don't.
The reflector is actually only about this diameter.
Everything we do has to go through this one hatch.
So they're working down there and they're going around things with these long
tools. It's arduous, it's difficult, but they've, they're very talented at it.
So it is difficult to get things out, but we do, we do it routinely every cycle,
and then they literally take them and they just keep them under water.
They drag them across to the other side of the pool, and then we can, uh,
we can store them. We can put them in shipping casks,
and then we can ship them over to the hot cells or wherever they're going to.
[Inaudible].
Fuel elements while they're not producing. Neutrons are many neutrons.
They are still producing a tremendous amount of gamma radiation.
So we use these, uh,
we have developed a small canister that can go down into that flux trap area.
And we can, uh, fill that canister.
We can stream water or electricity or whatever we want into that canister we can
do. High-intensity gamma radiation. These are our control plates.
You can see that I described the two cylinders. Okay.
That was a little bit of a stretch. They are two cylinders,
but the inner cylinder is one contiguous cylinder.
The outer cylinder is actually made up of four plates.
And you can see one of these plates here on the window sill. That's, uh,
an example of a control plate. These are very difficult to fabricate it,
take a tremendous amount of time. They are very expensive.
Remember these have europium oxide inside as a meat. And, uh,
they take two years to fabricate a set like this. So when we do shipments,
we can actually back a truck in here and it comes right over to this area where
these gray squares are.
And we can use the big crane and bring the big shipping cask and set it down.
The shipping cask for California, two 52 targets is quite large.
It's a nine foot diameter sphere that they've painted white and call the cue
ball. It weighs 25 tons. So it's not, it's not insignificant.
And it can get set onto a truck.
Very exciting when they ship California and plutonium targets are shipped in the
same, in the same cask.
I was really impressed that they're using this reactor for
all sorts of different experiments, not just making the new elements.
They also have beamlines coming out from the
reactor generating beams of neutron.
The reactor core is that way the beam,
you can see the red lines designate three beam lines.
There's actually a fourth one on the far, right? It doesn't get a red line.
So we have four beam lines that come down and they actually get split even
further because we have more than four instruments out here.
So these large tanks are called sands tanks.
Small-angle neutron scattering tanks. They get evacuated.
There's a detector plate, the large one meter square detector plate inside.
And they can use the beams of neutrons for what's called neutron
diffraction,
which will allow you to do all sorts of interesting experiments.
The one that really excited me was that you can take a diesel engine
like for a car,
and you can image that fuel being squirted into the
engine block by signing neutrons through the block of a running engine.
And because the fuel contains hydrogen atoms,
which absorb nutrients strongly,
you can see this jet of fuel going into names.
And when it's running without disturbing any of the
workings of the engine.
Have you seen our new periodic videos website yet? We made it with Wix,
which is the sponsor of today's episode. This is what it looks like.
And if you're creating a new website or maybe ditching an old one,
because it's become a nightmare to maintain,
then you really should have a look at Wix.
Their drag and drop interface makes designing a website. So simple, elegant.
It's actually kind of fun too.
You can stick pretty close to their huge range of templates to get things going.
Or you can go really deep with customization,
tweaking every tiny little part of the site.
You can even customize things I didn't know, existed on our website.
They've got everything,
go to wix.com/go/periodic videos use that slash
periodic videos. So they know you came from here,
whatever you're doing these days, you really should have a website.
And Wix is the place to go to make it
wix.com/go/periodic videos.
Wal-Mart is in the middle of South Australia.
Wilmer is actually an Aboriginal word profiling device.
And that's how they appropriately cause launching rockets and things. Yeah,
the black stump. So here they are taking all their supplies.
Australian service, men and scientists pay the big pot in the operation,
which included the construction of a tire.
The tire that vanished instantly when the atomic weapon was exploded on it.